i'm greg jarboe and what is that I mean
what we're going to talk about in this
first module of a content marketing
foundation course is liberally content
marketing I okay what is it so content
marketing is not a new concept it's been
around for over a hundred years in fact
one of the classic foundation stories of
you know the birth of content marketing
goes all the way back to the Michelin
brothers in France and the Michelin
brothers you know in case you haven't
done your history that's okay you know
we'll refresher right now were two
brothers who made pneumatic tires and
they were trying to sell them along with
an innovative product at its time called
the automobile in an era where the roads
were horrible in a place France where
frankly people didn't like to get
outside of Paris and into the provinces
because my god what was worth going up
there for you know or Paris that's all
happening here and what the Michelin
brothers realized is if they wanted to
sell more tires they had to get people
to drive farther and farther and use
them so what they come up with the
concept that really is the birth of
content marketing in my book was the
Michelin Guide and the Michelin Guide
was unique in that it reviewed
restaurants not just restaurants nearby
in Paris but restaurants out there in
the provinces and the Michelin brothers
are the ones who came up with the one
two and three star rating system to say
this restaurant I know it's way out
there it's you know bad roads but guess
what
to die for the ratatouille oh you you
got to have it this is a three-star
restaurant you you it's worth making the
trip and oh by the way since we're going
to give you a guide and you have to get
out of Paris in order to get there we're
going to tell you where you can find
gasoline along the way which hotels you
might want to stay out overnight and
the way just in case you have to how to
repair a flat tire particularly if it's
a Michelin tire because it's a pneumatic
and you know what it's quite easy to
repair and guess what that put Michelin
on the map why they weren't trying to
sell you more tires they weren't telling
you about the features and benefits of
round or a tire repair I mean that was
in there but it was only a how-to
article not necessarily a feature and
benefit what they were doing was they
were speaking to their audience about
what their audience was truly passionate
about which in Paris in 1900 was food
and by creating content but got the
audience to get into their new
innovative automobile and drive all the
way out there into the provinces for
that absolutely remarkable three-star
restaurant people got more flats people
had to replace their tires but it was
worth it and oh by the way michelin sold
more tires so that that's a great story
every time you sort of you know hit a
pause and like well we're doing content
marketing we need to come up with a
concept bank back to the Michelin Guide
it's it's great foundation so let's go
to a modern definition where are we now
in the 21st century when it comes to
content marketing well you can read the
slide here and read the definition and
some people like reading definitions I'm
not going to read it to you but I am
going to highlight a couple of words in
the definition that I think are
absolutely critical to any definition of
content marketing the content that you
create needs to be relevant and it also
has to be valuable now if it's not
relevant then you're not actually
meeting my needs or interests you know
and why would I be interested in them
and we've gotten way too tired of
screening out the commercial that comes
on
you know trying to sell us snow tires
and pardon me we live in Florida I don't
use the new tires what the heck is this
commercial doing you know interrupting
what I'm watching
so relevance is important relevance
means that this content isn't going to
get screened out and the valuable the
valuable can can work in a lot of
different ways it can be interesting it
can be useful you know value is an
interesting proposition all by itself
but that's the key to content marketing
it's not just creating more spam it's
not just throwing more trash over the
fence and hoping something happens this
is something where if you've created
valuable and relevant content you know
what your customers will find you that's
a whole different kind of proposition
[Music]
hey once you become an expert in digital
marketing then subscribe to the simply
learned Channel and click here to watch
more such videos turn up and get
certified in digital marketing click
here